I saw this video on how Star Wars was  saved in the edit exactly bro A New Hope  yeah saved in the edit by a team of  editors one of which was his wife so  basically Lucas  shot A New Hope like a dumbass had all  these  stupid ass scenes in there he's like  look at that and then his wife Marsha  was like you [ __ ] dumbass exactly I  went down he he was like look how  realized this world is look how realized  it is in this extra 20-minute scene we  need a whole other Ark in Tatooine we  should cut back to Tatooine Marshall's  like no we don't need that dude let's  have [ __ ] look fly through the  [ __ ] Death Star on the next Wing bro  yeah and speaking of X-Wing I'm about to  be your ex dude later bro so go find a  wingman  [ __ ] torched Lucas dad  did he kind of bone her didn't even bone  that's why they broke up